so dr. pouchy is being asked as the
country begins to reopen how they should
reopen part of the reason the country is
reopening so soon is because we the
people just refused to accept the new
normal and this state of lockdown for
months and months and years and years
here in LA and in many places around the
country
they said that churches weren't going to
open up for months churches weren't
gonna open up for years and then all the
rest of us said now I don't think so and
then Trump's DOJ said no I don't think
so
so now finally they're beginning to open
up the churches but what dr. Fauci says
is we should not have Holy Communion
we're not allowed to have holy communion
it's you know it's too dangerous as a
direct quote I think for the time being
you just gotta forestall that so what
that she said to America which is a
left-wing Jesuit magazine Catholic
magazine so now the doctor foul she the
exalted dr. fat she is making not only
our political decisions for us but our
religious decisions as well all in the
name of what you guessed it science
science the overarching political and
religious structure in the country first
of all the lab coats have no right to
make these kinds of decisions for us
okay we like their advice we're glad
that they give us advice they have no
right to be making these kinds of
decisions
second of all the lab coats the experts
the exalted scientists have been wrong
even in their own field even in the very
narrow category of concepts that they
can give some expertise in they've been
wrong from the very beginning they've
been wrong on how the virus would spread
how bad the virus would be who the virus
would affect have how the virus and when
the virus would go away they've been
wrong about everything but now we're not
only allowing them to dictate our
politics to us we're allowing them to
dictate our religious life to that's
because we've outsourced our politics to
these lab coats and we've outsourced our
religion to them as well that has been a
project of the left going all the way
back to Karl Marx they've they've wanted
government by the
by the experts so that we don't have any
debate any longer because the path to
history is so so clear because there's a
progressive utopia we're all in on the
path there's really nothing to argue
about anymore
well that isn't true that project failed
we should take our politics back and
certainly we should take our religion
back and I hope that pastors and priests
and bishops grow a spine and stand up to
this kind of nonsense because well well
doctor foul she might think that man can
live by bread alone mere mere bread
alone the rest of us no that is not true
[Music]
[Music]